boa tarde todo mundo é o fato de a gente
não vê ninguém ajuda um pouco como
cantar né
é eu queria começar agradecendo o
pessoal do ted com o convite
o felipe guilherme em particular e o
pessoal do parque a dani é beatriz é ali
e o davi por terem dado força pra gente
é construir um roteiro dessa história ea
história que eu queria contar pra vocês
é a história de uma bolinha não é
exatamente a minha história mas vocês
vão ver que eu me envolvo um pouco com a
história dessa bolinha pra gente falar
um pouco da história desta bolinha é
muito importante se fixar primeiro nesse
mapa que vocês estão vendo aí na tela o
que eu gostaria de mostrar nesse mapa
nesse mapa vocês estão vendo dois
problemas de saúde pública da mais alta
relevância para um momento em que a
gente vive
vocês vêem no lado direito há o mapa da
aids que é sabidamente ninguém
discutiria isso um problema da mais alta
relevância para o mundo inteiro e vocês
vêm do lado esquerdo
o mapa de distribuição da
esquistossomose
a esquistossomose é uma doença que a
gente se acostumou a estudar no segundo
grau mas que a gente ouve e fala pouco
dela ela não recebe muita atenção ela é
chamada uma doença negligenciada por quê
porque se vocês olharem com atenção o
mapa que está aqui a atrás de mim vocês
vão perceber que a esquistossomose elas
se distribuem essencialmente entre
países pobres e atinge pessoas pobres
que não têm dinheiro para comprar
medicamentos nem pagar tratamentos de
saúde e esse lado terrível dessa doença
faz com que os grandes laboratórios que
cuidam do tratamento de pessoas
desenvolvimento de remédios não se
ocupem muito da esquistossomose
apesar de em termos absolutos perceba
que não repara não estou comparando a
importância das doenças
mas se você comparar o número de pessoas
acometidas pela doença
não seria nenhum exagero dizer que estou
moss é um problema dez meses
mais importante do que a aids em termos
do número de pessoas que ficam doentes
ea despeito disso ela tem muito menos
visibilidade do que a aids é uma doença
mais democrática que ataca países ricos
e países pobres e portanto afeta pessoas
que têm condição de fazer tratamento é
um aspecto é particular
é dessa doença que da esquistossomose é
o que torna o problema do ponto de vista
social ainda mais grave é que ela comete
preferencialmente crianças
a esquistossomose causa a famosa barriga
d'água a barriga d'água é é por conta da
infecção da infestação de alguns órgãos
do organismo por um verme ela cresce
acumula líquidos causa é todo tipo de
problema fisiológico e pode inclusive
matar e ela ataca principalmente as
crianças porque as crianças têm um bom
costume de se divertir com água ea
esquistossomose no ciclo que ela se
desenvolve
vocês estão vendo uma foto e é muito
feia do xisto soma do verme que ataca as
crianças é horroroso objetivo é mais
causar essa sensação de repúdio mesmo
ele cria ele tem uma fase da vida que
ele fica dentro do organismo ele ataca o
fígado o baço em destino se aloja em
determinadas porções do organismo e bota
uma quantidade absurda de ovos a fêmea e
para o desenvolvimento o ciclo natural
desse desse verme os ovos
eles precisam encontrar eclodir dentro
de um caramujo caramujo esse que se
encontrado um infectado com fezes das
pessoas é é ajuda o desenvolvimento da
segunda fase dessa doença e até a
eclosão ea e o desenvolvimento da larva
que eventualmente volta para o ser
humano por conta da água contaminada é
como as crianças
estão nos rios com mais freqüência do
que os adultos
como elas estão brincando com as águas
fétidas poluídas com mais freqüência do
que os adultos
elas são mais freqüentemente acometidas
pela doença do que os adultos
isso também ajuda a explicar por que
essa doença se desenvolve principalmente
nos países pobres é porque nos países
pobres
o sistema de limpeza e de saneamento
de forma geral é um pouco pior do que
nos países desenvolvidos para você
tratar essa doença como ela é uma doença
negligenciada e ela recebe pouca atenção
dos grandes laboratórios e pouca atenção
dos grandes conglomerados farmacêuticos
são poucos os as substâncias químicas
que podem ser usadas para tratar essa
doença
vocês estão vendo aí no quadro a fórmula
química eu sou engenheiro químico tinha
que encontrar um jeito de apresentar a
fórmula química achei não é essa forma
feia que estão vendo aí o praziquantel
que é o medicamento um composto que é o
mais popular é o mais usado no mundo
inteiro para tratar a esquistossomose
qual é o problema do prazo com theo aqui
a gente tem dois problemas graves deste
medicamento
problema número um ele é amargo pra
dedéu ele é muito amargo e eu sei disso
porque eu também já tomei e se esse
remédio e isso causa um problema enorme
quando ele vai ser dado para a criança
que tende a rejeitar esse medicamento
ela tende a vomitar a recusar
ela não quer tomar depois de tomar uma
vez é o dificilmente quer tomar a
segunda e isso prejudica muito o
tratamento da doença e duas de
eficiência reduz a eficácia do
tratamento da esquistossomose cv que vão
somando uma série de pequenos fatores
não é que tornam esse cenário tão
dramático para os países pobres como o
brasil que são acometidos por essas
doenças que se dizer
estima se que no brasil a despeito da
baixa visibilidade das questões o nosi
existem entre 5 e 8 milhões de pessoas
doentes de esquistossomose se vê que é
um problema de enorme magnitude
e esse medicamento esse composto químico
tem um outro problema como a criança ou
a pessoa precisa tomar grandes
quantidades desse medicamento para poder
acabar com verba está instalado dentro
do organismo
os comprimidos são muito grandes como os
comprimidos são muito grandes e as doses
são muito grandes de novo as crianças
rejeitam o medicamento porque é difícil
de engolir e obriga a mãe da criança por
exemplo até que reparte o tamanho do
remédio para adequá dose há o peso da
criança
tudo isso atrapalha o tratamento e
diminui a eficiência e eficácia do do
combate à esquistossomose
por essa razão o ministério da saúde é
transformou o problema da
esquistossomose em uma das prioridades
do da saúde pública no brasil é em
particular o ministério da saúde busca
uma solução de praziquantel remédio uma
formulação farmacêutica de praia hotel
o medicamento usado para tratar a
esquistossomose que não tenha gosto
porque dessa maneira seria possível ou
será possível reduzir a resistência que
as crianças têm ao medicamento
uma possível solução para esse problema
é que vocês estão vendo aí na tela é a
gente esconder ou como a gente fala e
tecnicamente encapsula esse medicamento
em bolinhas suficientemente pequenas
para que as crianças possam tomar o
medicamento e não sinto o gosto do
medicamento
essa foto que vocês estão vendo na tela
ela representa partículas que têm
dimensão de 100 nanômetros lembrando
quem não fez o curso de ciências exatas
um nanômetro significa milionésima parte
do metro é um tamanho muito pequeno
mesmo
estima-se da ordem de mil vezes tem um
diâmetro dessa bolinha mil vezes menor
que o diâmetro de um fio de cabelo é um
texto típico que aparece quando a gente
fala de nós
a tecnologia ea idéia é botar o remédio
dentro dessa bolinha pra que ele não
entre em contato com a páscoa as papilas
gustativas ea criança assim não sinto
gosto não sentindo o gosto ela evite
rejeitar o problema eu aprendi que na
engenharia
todo grande problema importante começa
com uma compreensão um problema simples
como esse
o medicamento que tem um gosto ruim mas
você colocar o medicamento dentro de uma
bolinha de 100 nanômetros é que é uma
tecnologia muito sofisticada essa
bolinha também não pode ser muito grande
porque se ela for muito grande ela vai
causar sensação de uma areia alguma
coisa que irrita e a criança ea pessoa
vai rejeitar de novo então a gente tem
que ter um controle muito adequado do
tamanho dessa bolinha para que a solução
seja efetiva
bom a gente tenta resolver problemas
como esse num laboratório da coppe
chamado de em japão o laboratório de
engenharia de polímeros
o que vocês estão vendo aí nessa foto é
uma instalação que permite o que a gente
chama de escalonamento dos processos que
é transformar uma coisa que a gente faz
em pequeníssima as quantidades dentro do
laboratório em quantidades que sejam
suficientemente grandes para que tenham
importante importância social ea gente
desenvolveu uma solução tecnológica para
produzir essa bolinha e produzir o
remédio para combater esquistossomose
sem gosto
e aí eu queria pegar esse mote e
convergir para de fato qual é a mensagem
o tema principal que eu gostaria de
discutir com vocês
você não quer pensar o que falar 10
minutos sobre o que não é o tema central
o tema central aqui é que a universidade
ela está preparada e ela deve de fato
empreender em ouvir a sociedade e ouvir
os problemas que a sociedade tem é muito
comum a gente ver ainda dentro da
universidade e eu vou aqui é falar no
tema bastante polêmico mas normalmente o
brinco com meus filhos já vou fazer 53
anos
falar o que pensa senão vou ter
oportunidade de falar o que penso nunca
e há gente na universidade às vezes tem
um discurso da liberdade acadêmica do
docente do pesquisador que de fato a
gente tem que pensar o que a gente
quiser de fato a gente tem que dizer o
que a gente quiser mas a gente tem que
estar com ouvidos abertos às
necessidades da sociedade em particular
na sociedade brasileira então cheia de
problemas como aqui nós como é que nós
temos a universidade ela tem a obrigação
de procurar de ramal conhecimento que
ela desenvolve para a sociedade que nos
cerca
não adianta que nós pesquisadores
ficamos presos ou numa torre de marfim
estudando temas que nós consideramos os
mais relevantes se esse conhecimento de
alguma forma não chega a sociedade não
beneficia a sociedade de alguma maneira
em particular é importante que se diga
eu sou professor universitário 30 anos e
eu sou pago por vocês estão me
assistindo neste momento então a gente
tem obrigação de dar retorno a quem nos
paga que é a sociedade que nos abriga e
o que não falta são problemas no brasil
pra gente se ocupado deles e tentar
resolver eu estou dizendo que a
universidade não participa desse
processo
muito pelo contrário quem tá socorro tem
quem está acompanhando a questão do zico
neste momento sabe que as universidades
institutos de pesquisa estão procurando
se envolver o máximo possível com o tema
mas é preciso fazer mais ea gente tem um
outro problema muito grave no brasil que
atrapalha essa questão empreendedora que
se chama burocracia ou burocracia quando
a gente quer falar mal dela é o país ele
se acostumou a exigir uma quantidade
absurdamente grande de controle de todos
os tipos para que a gente tenha
condições de empreender e às vezes torna
quase impossível você empreender no país
eu vou dar um exemplo pra vocês que têm
a ver com a história dessa bolinha e que
fique bem claro não estou aqui me
queixando eu estou contando uma história
nesse projeto por
exemplo nós estamos há um ano em que a
universidade federal do rio de janeiro
resolveu que concorda desenvolver a
solução médica o ministério da saúde
concordem desenvolver a solução médica o
bnds concordem desenvolver a a apoiar
economicamente o desenvolvimento dessa
solução médica a fiocruz concorda em ser
parceira desse processo e nós estamos há
um ano sem conseguir assinar um contrato
de parceria por conta da burocracia da
seda da certidão disso da certidão
daquilo do controle digital de tal coisa
que tem que ser feito e no país a gente
esquece que importante é fazer se a
gente empurra o processo de empreendedor
nós não conseguimos fazer e nós não
conseguimos avançar
eu gosto de imaginar que nessa até tem
uma quantidade muito grande de pessoas
de pequena de de idade é baixa entre
algo muito abaixo de 20 anos boa parte
entre 20 e 30 anos e vocês têm a
obrigação de mudar esse quadro no brasil
contém certamente com o meu apoio
existem vários lugares na universidade
onde a gente ensina essa obrigação de
empreender e onde a gente aprende essa
obrigação de empreender
eu tenho alguns exemplos aqui é um
número que me impressionou desde que eu
cheguei no parque tecnológico foi que
existem 700 movimentos empreendedores
catalogados pela ufrj independente esse
é um número absurdamente grande boa
parte de vocês que estão aqui que está
aqui e que está envolvido o movimento
empreendedor sabe disso mas esse número
e essas iniciativas não tem a
visibilidade que ela merece
nós precisamos aprofundar essa questão
empreendedora na universidade
a gente vê aqui as empresas gênios que
tem um papel muito importante na forma
essas pessoas
a incubadora de empresas onde sua boa
ideia precisa ser apoiada pela
universidade para que se transforme em
uma boa empresa que vai ajudar a
sociedade resolver seus problemas
empresa boa essa que pode ser recebida e
muito bem recebida no parque tecnológico
da ufrj
nós então temos caminhos isso não quer
dizer que nós estamos muito bem não eu
que estou dizendo é que existem caminhos
e que a gente tem que aprofundar levar e
dar visibilidade a todos esses
movimentos dentro da ufrj eu gosto muito
desse quadro porque aqui de novo a gente
tem de ver dois gráficos no seu lado
esquerdo
você vê a produção científica brasileira
hoje o brasil ocupa a depender do
ranking em de uma posição entre o 14º eo
11º lugar entre o maior produtor de
pesquisa de conhecimento no mundo o que
é uma coisa bacana ainda não é
comparável ao tamanho da nossa economia
mas não é um número do qual a gente se
envergonha
no entanto quando a gente fala sobre
inovação e atividades empreendedoras não
arranque no mundo que coloca o brasil
acima da 70ª posição o que significa
dizer que ilustra de maneira cabral
cabal que a gente está pecando em
alcoitão e pecando na nossa capacidade
de levar o conhecimento gerado dentro
das instituições brasileiras para a
sociedade que mantém essas instituições
e que precisa ver os seus problemas
resolvidos e apoiados por aqueles que
estão pensando então eu queria terminar
essa apresentação com essa foto que
mostra de novo as bolinhas uma solução
desenvolvida no seio da universidade
federal do rio de janeiro e que fala
tanto sobre as dificuldades que nós
temos pra gerar elevar o conhecimento
que nós produzimos a sociedade as
pessoas mais necessitadas que de fato
nos mantém essa é a nossa obrigação e é
por isso que eu queria deixar essa
mensagem final
nós temos a missão ea obrigação de
empreender para transformar na
universidade pública brasileira sigam em
frente e atendam a esse convite
sou parceiro dessa luta grande abraço
para todo mundo
[Aplausos]